alors à 10 donc je voulais dire un
automobiliste est un candidat monte à
l'arrière de sa fourgonnette et que
va-t-il se passer après regarde on y va
monsieur allait alors le conducteur a
freiné brusquement le candidat va tombé
du véhicule on va découvrir que le
conducteur et le père bouras une sorte
de père fouras la baie je la connais par
coeur
tab et l'abbé l'année à bab merci à vous
et moi de vous avoir réveillé la baie
merci aux visites la baie il tombe c'est
là non il fred et il se défonce la tête
surtout regarder je vous ai dit
doucement au bordel c'est bon allez
vas-y roule mais doucement doucement
merde
[Applaudissements]
après des heures d'efforts un candidat
arrive enfin à son but il est sur le
point de quoi
ce qui va se passer le candidat va
tomber à l'eau il est donc sur un point
il va tomber à l'eau le candidat va
réussir à se blesser sans bouger on va
découvrir que le candidat n'est autre
que jean michel maire à vence et un
plomb l'abbé ballerines et l'abbaye s'il
a bel et bien gardé alors se tenir
[Musique]
c'est pas beau talent et un candidat
cherche de l'aide dans une rue regardez
ces wolkowitsky qui doit être adressée
aux frais alors c'est quoi la suite le
candidat pas oublier qu'il ya une caméra
un candidat a pas s'en va insulter
l'équipe de tournage où l'église du
village va sonner pour l'annoncer le
secteur la baie a pas 120 selon la bc
vote brévine ont regardé c'est pas la
belle et la bête est ravi que c'est aux
frères et donc messieurs messieurs sur
la caméra il se prends la caméra il ya
un des ponts c'est pas si c'est d'aider
du regard des années regardent ils
frappent la caméra et donc je ne sais
pas ce que c'est ça oui je pense qu'ils
se les manger mais grave grave
j'ai regardé savoir qu'ils n'étaient pas
là vous inquiétez pas la balistique
on va regarder un passage de la carte
aux trésors où un candidat demande à
être voiture de lady au jour à dame
je cherche le centre traditionnel de
musique alors que va-t-il se passer la
conductrice d'oublier candidats la
voiture va rouler sur le pied du
cameraman ou olivier de carglass va
débarquer s'occuper du parent ou
l'algérie
le monsieur vélo connaît ce que vous
pouvez suivre
elle est partie n'a pas compris a reçu
le vélo à nous oublier madame
[Applaudissements]